hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of the melt weather champions
chester finals uh it's the first game
between magnus carlson and wesley so i
know you guys were really uh looking
forward to this matchup and uh already
in game one we have a very exotic
opening choice by magnus so let's dive
straight into it magnus with the white
pieces opens with b3 and this is
probably the
the
opening that most people are talking
about nowadays online as everyone is
started using it but now after the
tournament is already over well the
chester is over i guess magnus sees no
harm in giving it a try against his
rival wesley so so let's see uh how it
goes um against him we have d5 by wesley
and going for the classical reply
against this name so larson attack uh we
have bishop to b2 and now knight to f6
we have knight to f3 and here many moves
are possible and many moves have been
played but wesley chooses h6 it's a move
that has been played only a handful of
times and it's very unlikely that magnus
has anything prepared against this so g3
magnus ready to think out of his uh
light square bishop castle to safety and
now bishop to f5 closing uh developing
the light core bishop before closing the
pawn chain and now there is one game
where bishop to g2 was played but here
wesley plays e6 uh sorry
magnus plays d3 and it is now only as of
move five that we have a completely new
game so wesley grabs more space in the
center we have c5 and now bishop to g2
we have knight to c6 continuing
development uh and now knight to e5 an
excellent square for the knight if
wesley wants to trade then bishop can
simply capture and it will be an
excellent square for the bishop at least
for the moment so knight captures bishop
captures uh and now finally e6 um
closing the structure as the light
square bishop is now out of this
structure so knight to d2 magnus
continues development uh has a very nice
support for e4
and bishop to e7 wesley also continues
developing e4 now striking in the center
and the bishop to g6 uh magnus castles
now he also has some ideas of maybe
playing uh f4 f5 and wesley just castles
we have queen to e2 uh connecting the
rooks developing the queen and now
bishop to h5 asking the queen to uh
politely move or you have to block with
f3 but if you block with f3 you can't
play f4 at least not right away but this
is what magnus goes for he plays f3 and
now knight to d7 attacking the bishop
and now wesley also might have some
ideas of uh advancing his f pawn so
magnus goes back bishop to b2
and d captures an e4 now the pawn cannot
capture as it spins so you can only
capture with the knight or the other
pawn uh we have d captures on e5 now
clearing up the d file for the for the
white rook and now uh wesley strikes in
the center with f5 and now uh magnus
could play a lot of things for example
just bringing the rook to d1 is one that
makes sense but magnus decides to
capture an f5 and it's a really
it's a move i can't explain but i'm sure
there there's a reason it was played
because why not just leave this weak
pawn on e6 maybe it can be attacked
later on uh why allow uh wesley to get
rid of his weak pawn that is beyond me
but okay we have e captures on f5 e
captures on f5 and now rook 8 to d1 now
the knight the rook is uh
nicely placed here on the d file uh
x-raying the black queen on d8 and
bishop to f6 uh offering this bishop
that wasn't doing all that much to trade
it against the carlson's very nice
bishop uh that's been controlling this
entire diagonal so here bishop captures
an f6 queen captures uh and now knight
the c4 opening up a discovery here on
the night but before that wesley of
course um
uh
doesn't want to waste any tempe so rook
8 e8 challenging the queen so first you
have to move and then we're gonna
deal with the knight being attacked so
queen to f2 and now rook to e7 nicely
defending and if needed you can always
double up on the file you can double up
on the e file so very very flexible
setup from wesley
rook to d6 attacking the queen here and
the queen to c3 now
we have rooked back to d3 again
attacking the queen queen back to f6
asking magnus are you maybe interested
in a nice draw by repetition but magnus
says nope not for the moment so he plays
rook after d1 doubles up on the d file
puts pressure on the knight here and now
knight to e5 attacking the knight here
attacking the rook here so rook to d6
attacking the queen and now queen back
to f7 and only now does magnus straight
on e5 so knight captures rook captures
and now it's a very interesting position
but there is one move that gives the
magnus advantage to continue pushing
this game uh so feel free to pause the
video and try to spot this idea while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
only move that gives uh
white uh some advantage and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show the
move is f4 that's the good stuff
attacking the rook even though you allow
black to capture your rook on d1 it's
still uh definitely worth it uh some of
you might have thought about bishop to
f1 with the idea of just winning the
game on the spot but after king to h7
it's still not
not all that much and maybe the bishop
is better placed on g2 so but it's it's
a valid attempt so congratulations to
anyone who thought about bishop to f1 as
well but okay after rook captures an e5
like we said f4 another thing is if you
capture on the one we capture on e5 and
we already have a past pawn the the pawn
is coming to e6 we have we will have
very nice support along this diagonal uh
so maybe not the way to go this would be
very very easily winning for magnus so
instead after f4 wesley plays rook to e2
attacks carlson's queen here queen
captures on c5 that was the point we win
upon and we attack the a7 pawn
threatening to win another pawn b6
attacking the queen and now queen to c3
guardian is still guarding our uh c2
pawn so now wesley
says all right i'm down upon but i
better trade down to get rid of some of
the pressure so rook captures on g2 a
temporary exchange sacrifice king
captures as this was with check and now
bishop captures on d1 with rook captures
on d1 and now rook to e8 and now wesley
says okay i'm down upon but your king is
wide open
shouldn't really be a problem uh holding
this so magnus plays rook to e1 he says
i'm very interested in going into a
queen and pawn in the game but wesley
says no for the moment we keep the rooks
on the board queen d5 check king g1 and
now rook to d8 just nicely doubling up
on the d file and magnus plays a4 he has
a three to two advantage on the queen
side so at some point you might consider
uh pushing those pawns forward
we have a5 now wesley prevents any
further pawn pushes and now king to f2
magnus starts bringing the king into the
game king h7 and now queen to e5
offering a queen trade uh rook to e7 is
also a valid attempt uh you just uh
threaten uh checkmate and uh well here
you have to consider maybe queen to d2
just uh offering a queen trade or rook
to g8 which would be very passive
probably would see something like queen
to d2 and then a queen trade with check
then rule goes back of course we cannot
trade rooks we're down a pawn look back
to d6 and then we have this
rook end game
but for the moment magnus prefers to
keep to keep them on the board he plays
queen to e5 and now if wesley trades
maybe it would be a more favorable
position maybe he thought about
capturing with the f pawn it's very
unclear but for the moment wesley
doesn't trade wesley just moves back the
queen he plays queen back to f7 and now
rook to e2 not allowing any checks along
the second rank we have queen to h5 uh
and now again you have to be very
careful if the rook moves somewhere uh
ideas like rook to e8 might be possible
so uh it's a it's a it's a it's a nice
idea but also just uh threatening to
capture the h2 pawn so magnus has to
defend this and still okay the queen
keeps an eye on the rook uh rook to d5
now trying to get the queen away from
the defense so you can capture uh the
rook on e2 so magnus just steps back
queen to e3 and now b5 we're trying to
eliminate as many pawns um
as possible so a capture sun b5 we have
rook captures on b5 now we're gonna
create more weak pawns and now queen to
f3 now magnus offers a queen train and
now it's a wesley
that declines the trade because the
white king is wide open so having more
attacking power on the board it
definitely works better in your favor we
rook to e5 magnus offers a trade and now
it's hard to decline this because if you
move the rook you lose the a5 pawn if
you allow queen d3 then there will be a
double attack on this pawn if you
capture an e5 then you allow white to
have a very nice past e pawn so here
it's it's hard to hard to you know
choose between uh the lesser evil but
rook captures on e5 is definitely the
lesser evil so this is what wesley goes
for we have f captures on e5 and queen
to e6 now blocking the past pawn and now
queen to e2 so now magnus got what he
wanted a queen and pawn end game where
he's up upon that this is the most
complicated endgame that you can
possibly imagine uh you can learn them
all you want they will still be
incredibly difficult
so you know best is to just to just
practice it give me just one second
sorry about that i had to check if it
was anything important uh so after queen
to e2 we have queen to c6 with check and
now magnus plays king to f2 we have king
to g6 by wesley now comes h4 so they're
just grabbing more space on the king
side we have king to f7 and now h5 not
allowing any pawn pushes uh with uh some
like g5 or g6 uh if you did it now then
magnus would very happily capture and
you would have uh three pawn island so
not something you want to do so king to
e6 and now we have c4 uh that is now a
pass pawn that is now a pass pawn so
magnus the only one with a pass pawn
here not one but it's actually two pass
pawns so wesley has to create some
weaknesses he plays a4 uh challenges the
b3 pawn and okay magnus captures on a4
we have queen captures on a4 and now
queen to d3 uh keeping an eye on
everything uh and now uh preparing uh
just to start checking the black king so
the e5 pawn will be captured but you
can't keep an eye on everything uh
wesley captures it and now queen to d5
would check so but the material is now
is equal
but wesley's king is maybe a bit too
active but we'll see
one second
[Music]
sorry about that had to let meadow in in
the room uh so queen to d5 would check
king back to f6 and now queen to d6 with
check we have king to f7 and now queen
to g6 with check uh checking whether uh
you can win some pawns here maybe you
can win this one maybe you can win this
pawn king the g8 and now we have queen
to e6 with check and now uh it seems
like um
not that bad of a thing maybe if we move
our king white will capture this we're
gonna capture this but that's not how
chess works if wesley plays king to h8
magnus would just play queen to see it
with chicken after the king moves king
h7 only move will only useful move this
is also possible and then we just pick
up this pawn with check and then we
still protect our past pawn and we push
this pawn to victory so that would be
the idea so wesley can defend the pawn
he plays king f8 now we play queen
captures and if i would check uh king to
e7 and now queen to e5 with check king
f7 queen to d5 with check king to f6 and
now king to f3 magnus starts improving
the position of his king
before uh starting to push this past
pawn so queen b3 check king to g4 and
now queen to a2 uh still not allowing
this pawn to be pushed forward because
the queen would hang and also we're now
ready to deliver many checks um uh via
via the second rank so here queen to f5
check king to e7 and now queen to e4
with check asking wesley what do you do
here and there are many possible options
here and it's not easy making a choice
but wesley made the choice that uh
kind of made the
carlson's uh
well uh idea a little bit too easy uh he
played king to f6 and now he allowed
magnus this queen to g6 check move uh
and it was in this position on movie 61
that wesley so resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
the thing is uh it doesn't matter what
you do or where you go you're losing
this pawn with check and very very
likely this pawn would check as well uh
if you go king to e5 of course we just
capture this pawn with check so black
will never be in time to grab this pawn
and you cannot approach this pawn with
the king as both of these squares are
covered and if you try something else it
doesn't matter king e7 it's the same
thing we're going to capture with check
and not a worry in the world for white
if you go here we're going to capture
this pawn as well with check so of
course it's completely winning so there
you have it it was a draw it was a dead
draw it was a draw constantly but with
queen end games it's never a draw it's
never a draw even if it's equal material
it's never a draw if you're up upon
i once um i had an uh well a queen's end
game it was a classical game and if i
won that game i win the tournament uh
and i have a queen and pawn end game i
even traded down into it willingly i was
up a pawn and then all of a sudden i
could not win the game it was it was
constantly a draw constantly i draw and
then of course i over pushed and lost
the game so queen opponent games always
a joy for for everyone do study them as
they are you know very very complicated
uh so yeah game one goes to magnus uh uh
hope you guys enjoyed that and we're
gonna continue of course uh showing
showing this match since so many of you
requested it and of course the other
games from the tournament uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
i would like to wish a very happy
birthday to ana paola i hope you enjoyed
your your special day uh and i would
like to uh thank gary myers uh mark adam
uh uh fossa uh micah kennedy and
constantinos from piracy for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
very nice event checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world thank you i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day